the number one way to be successful in
making content on social platforms is
through the pack platforms and culture
what does it mean let's break it down
platforms if you do not know how the
platforms are acting Tick Tock LinkedIn
Facebook then you're not going to be
successful I'll give you an example
every one of you has your listings
listed on a website if you were to take
a screenshot of that listing on your
mobile device go to Instagram and Tick
Tock and put that image behind a green
screen and record yourself talking with
the listing behind you that video will
get five to ten times more views than if
you just do a selfie video inside the
listing because of the platform creative
strategy of green screens working as a
creative format